what's popping mutos it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is going to be a breakdown of
episode three of Monarch Legacy of
monsters that features another sighting
of the king of monsters himself and
ending with the reveal of the chillest
monster that we've ever seen and boy do
I mean chill so strap into your seats
gang cuz we're about to get into it and
the episode starts with the camera eye
of Monarch watching over a recently
Rogue Leland Shaw who at the end of the
last episode cut off the tracking
bracelet that Monarch had placed on him
while they had him in solitary
confinement a solitary confinement that
Tim's boss Natalia Verdugo later refers
to as a generous retirement so I am
super curious as to what exactly landed
this former military man into Monarch's
secret Slammer for sneaky seniors but
anyways after the gang steals a car from
the facility and starts to make their
escape I found it kind of hilarious how
the driver side rearview mirror somehow
manages to survive the chaos of them
ramming into everything only to randomly
and in in explicably break off screen
between these two shots while they were
just driving without any obstacles like
what the hell even happened there we do
later see that driver side mirror fixed
with black tape while the gang planned
their next move on that boat ride to
poang South Korea but anyways as the
gang finally breaks out of the facility
and hits the road you can see the same
Mountain from the Futaba Resting Home
brochure in the background then after a
super dope transition that Fades Kurt
Russell's face with his son Wyatt
Russell's face we catch up with a young
leash Shaw a young Bill Randa and the
soon to be covered in Kaiju bugs K mura
in 1954 a full two years after they all
encountered that winged saliva monster
amongst the wreckage of the USS slon at
the end of episode 2 KO and Bill Randa
are introduced to General Pucket played
by Christopher Hayer doll who I
absolutely loved as Captain lock and
Peacemaker fantastic actor but anyways
they then all head over to a giant
footprint of Godzilla that bill and Koo
discovered in Indonesia we actually do
see a picture that bill took of ko
discovering this footprint super briefly
on May's computer in the last episode
along with a picture of the nuclear
warhead that the general would end up
using to lure and explode Godzilla at
bikini atal later on in the episode with
bikini ad all of course being the
location that the American Military
famously conducted nuclear tests at a
place that is now unfortunately
abandoned due to the vast amounts of
radiation that still linger in the
region but speaking of that nuclear
Warhead when we first see it in the
episode there's a soldier painting the
same anti-g goodzilla symbol that the
people of Tokyo would end up using in
the future which is kind of weird
considering that none of these soldiers
here had ever seen Godzilla before so
I'm not exactly sure how they got such
an accurate depiction of this creature
though I can definitely see these
soldiers having somewhat of an idea of
what Godzilla could look like based on
reports from people across the world who
have seen Godzilla pop up before and
when the general asks how Godzilla could
possibly walk around the planet without
being seen Bill Randa brings up the
possibility of teleportation something
that Lee Shaw dissuades him against
doing later on because of how ludicrous
it sounds but I honestly don't think
that bill Randa is off here especially
after we got that flashback of Hoshi
Randa mysteriously teleporting to Kate's
location suspiciously quickly as soon as
Kate told him where she was over the
phone making me feel like this
hypothesis of teleportation might just
be a piece of foreshadowing for a
possible scientific discovery that Hoshi
Randa might have made about the
teleportation migration patterns of
Godzilla possibly even using that
discovery of teleportation to visit both
of his families in America and Japan
quickly and easily allowing him to have
that double life introducing the concept
of teleportation to the Godzilla
Universe would actually make sense as it
would serve as an explanation as to how
Godzilla is able to get to different
areas of the world as quickly as they do
there might just be a hidden
Subterranean network of portals that
monsters use to to travel the world
likely the same hidden Subterranean
network of gravity tunnels leading to
the hollow Earth in the center of the
earth that we learn about in Godzilla
versus Kong so Monarch Legacy of
monsters might actually end up being an
extension of the hollow Earth scientific
narrative with those coordinates that
Lee and may look over on the plane
possibly leading to different portals
across the planet but that's just my
weird Theory I could definitely see that
secret being one that Kate and kentaro's
father Hiroshi Randa would want to keep
from an organization of Monster Hunters
like monarch especially considering how
distraught hiroshi's mother K was at the
American military's use of a nuclear
bomb on Godzilla I feel like Hoshi
probably wanted to protect all the
monster life connected to that
Subterranean network of wormholes while
simultaneously keeping the secret of
teleportation away from the sketchy
power abusing organization Monarch has
become basically hoshi's way of
protecting his mother's Legacy and
honoring her wishes but only time will
tell moving on as the gang are tra
traveling on their boat to poang South
Korea we can see May on the phone with
an unknown friend telling them that she
might be coming back soon the way that
she talks to this person on the phone
makes me feel like she might have a
complicated but close history with that
person possibly implying that this
person might have been someone may could
have known intimately in the past but
for all we know it could also just be a
platonic hacker friend or even a family
member but my money is on somebody that
will make canaro jealous later on but
anyways when they get to customs in
poang South Korea and start standing in
the wrong line notice how Kate and
canaro are framed here with each of them
separated on different sides of this
clock reading 12:30 p.m. Kate on the
left side in front of line one and
canaro standing in front of line two
very much continuing this theme of
dualities that this show is all about as
evidenced by the symmetrical dualities
in the intro animation of the show check
out my breakdown of the first two
episodes of Monarch where I go into this
Show's excellent use of cinematography
to convey this theme of twos because it
is is honestly pretty damn incredible
and the artistic side of my brain loves
it so damn much but anyways when Tim's
boss comes to address the Randa
situation we learn that Tim had no prior
authorization for Monarch to go after
Bill randa's files and it seems that Tim
himself believes that randa's research
and discoveries could potentially help
the world prepare for another Titan
attack despite Monarch dismissing Bill
randa's research as a bunch of nonsense
so Tim not informing his higher ups that
he was going after Bill rand's research
of implies that not even Tim trusts the
higher upset Monarch with what is in
those files like it would be kind of
crazy if it was revealed that Tim was
the estranged biological son of Lee Shaw
later on in the series because it would
kind of make sense why Tim's partner
Duval vouches for Tim by telling their
boss that he's the most capable agent
that they have to track down Shaw but
anyways when we get a flashback to 1954
bikini at all Koo notes that she would
rather lose funding than obliterate a
living creature that they don't
understand just because they're Afra
afraid of it which is something that I
found to be super interesting and ironic
considering what we know about her
husband's future in Kong Skull Island
because John Goodman's 1970s Bill Rena
had the complete opposite mentality when
he gathered a bunch of military men to
hunt and kill Kong on Skull Island after
losing so many men at Sea to a monster
as the sole survivor of the USS Lon it
appears that bill Randa losing KO as
well could have pushed him over the edge
and caused him to adopt General pocket's
hatred and intolerance towards mutos and
later when the gang are on their plane
to Alaska sha tells Kate that her father
didn't lie to her about his monarch life
but was merely keeping a secret from her
echoing what Koo tells Lee's younger
self about keeping secrets for the
greater good after Lee informs KO and
Bill of the blank check that the
American Military wrote for them to
continue their Monster hunting research
and later when Bill Randa asks why they
just don't go public with what just went
down during that classified nuclear test
Young Lee Shaw references the
electrocution of Julius and Ethel
Rosenberg a sentencing carried out by
the US government just a year prior in
1953 after the couple was convicted of
sharing classified military and nuclear
information to the Soviet Union but
anyways as the plane ride continues in
the modern day May references Yeti
sightings in Alaska which could
potentially be a bit of foreshadowing
considering how we saw an image of what
appeared to be Bigfoot in Bill randa's
files so having a Yeti show up at some
point in the series would be a surprise
to be sure but a welcome one and
speaking of surprises after Kate and
canaro discover signs that their father
survived the destruction of his plane
their pilot quickly realizes that
hoshi's plane was actually destroyed by
a mudo after a safe landing before
promptly being killed by that very same
creature that the pilot was trying to
escape from leaving the gang stranded in
the mountains alone to face an angry
spiky Frost Kaiju modeled after a star
noosed mole if a star-nosed mole could
suck you so hard that you turned into a
popsicle God do I regret saying that
sentence but no I genuinely wonder what
the hell is going to happen in this next
episode because these people are screwed
I have no clue what's going to happen
that's going to save them from this mess
outside of Godzilla showing up out of
nowhere if there is actually a portal at
this location I hope they find it quick
because uh I do not see how they get out
of this but they obviously have to so I
cannot wait for episode 4 but anyways
that is it for this break down of
Monarch Legacy of monsters episode 3
what do you guys think of this episode
and how are you guys feeling this series
in general let us know in the comment
section below you can follow Me @
mastertainment on Instagram and Twitter
or wherever I am on the internet if you
guys want to see me post some weird
but most importantly don't forget to
subscribe to heavy spoilers here on
YouTube cuz we always got some fun stuff
for you guys and also if you're feeling
generous feel free to hit that like
button because every like always helps
the channel but again thank you guys so
so so much for watching this video you
guys are amazing and I'll see you guys
soon
goodbye